[Music]
jennifer lopez and ben affleck want to
get married soon
this includes one of many new details et
is learning about their upcoming
nuptials i'm ready i'm excited about it
following their engagement announcement
back in april benefit 2.0 is now
discussing locations for their i do's
a source tells et the couple is talking
about having a destination or tropical
wedding
the source adds ben and jen's kids will
be involved in their wedding as well as
the two are excited to unify their
families even further
i want to give it away but it has a very
good ending
this couple has also been spotted house
hunting and privacy is at the top of
their must list the source explains ben
and jen want a home in a very exclusive
private neighborhood that has a ton of
land with high level security
they're excited to find a home and spend
even more time together there than they
already do it was totally unexpected
what else was unexpected the full
breakdown jlo gave her fans of the
moment ben proposed my love came in ben
came in and got down on one knee
and he said some things that i'll never
forget
then he pulled out a ring
and he said will you marry me
and it was
the most perfect moment
he hands me a ring
and he said it's a green diamond
my favorite color
and yes jen enlisted her filmmaker beau
to direct this video
ben even makes an off-screen cameo at
the end feeling so lucky it's not often
we get a
second chance at true love
we feel very lucky
and who else loves that rock that she's
got the couple's children
another source tells e.t the kids are
all very excited and have been telling
her how pretty and huge the ring is
in fact the engagement will be a start
to finish family affair
you know it's wild to think about it
that way the source goes on to reveal
jen definitely wants a wedding and wants
to share the moment in a bigger way she
loves the idea of marrying the love of
her life and then partying after with
their family and friends
plus ben makes yet another cameo in an
upcoming jlo project
i want something real
in a short but powerful moment in the
trailer for jen's documentary halftime
which chronicles her preparation for the
2020 super bowl halftime show the couple
gets candid about fame
i've lived in the public eye
and i really believe a lot of what they
said diva serial bride
i said to her once doesn't this bother
you and she said i expected this
with the roller coaster ride the
couple's been through they seem to be
able to overcome it all the source also
says they can't wait to spend the rest
of their lives together forever happily
in love
[Music]